my advice to Young filmmaker is to make  a movie every week write every night and  every weekend shoot for two days and  work with actors work with a little 1  000 watt lighting kit set it up set up  your shots get a tripod shoot a little  scene work with the actors cut those  scenes together and then the next  weekend have worked on it with sound and  looping and put some music to it it  could all be done for nothing nowadays  with the computer and get a response  from the audience and see where it's  slow and where it doesn't work and where  your ideas weren't being communicated  properly learn from that experience  sitting in with the crowd then go out  and make another picture the next  weekend and just keep doing it make  films no matter what anybody says and  you'll be a filmmaker